مدير موارد بشرية طقوس
هذا العالم هو الشيطان
[موسيقى]
ربما المنظمة الوحيدة الكبيرة
في روسيا الذين يشاركون في الحماية
اصناف نادرة
[موسيقى]
مشاريع الترميم الأولى
تجمع الجينات
إنه ليس مجرد حيوان مفترس ، إنه مؤشر على ذلك
حالة الطبيعة التي
ماذا نفعل بأرضنا
يزيل الندوب العميقة
نعتبر أنفسنا سادة التكبير
sakhalin أنفسهم شرائط منزعج نوعا ما
بقي الفيلم الفعلي doirean على دا
ومقال من أهل هالي جالي
[موسيقى]
أمرت adonis reale jori dicere
مقابر في الدوري
هنا في ذلك الوقت أود أن أنقر على dbv آل
بيدا بيدانت 1 اكسارا اكسارا مين الكسندر
جاء الدب القطبي اليوم
بعض الشباب تماما دون خوف
يقولون جلسوا أمام المكعب والرجال
من رآه على القناة هيا بنا
صرخات
نحن الآن نذهب إلى أسلاف كيب تانرز
أطلق عليه اسم السوق والقلم لأنه هنا
لطالما كان هناك الكثير من حيوانات الفظ تاتيانا مينين
الغاز والحديث القاع من قبل moesaki أكثر
bocharov في حالة سكر من أنها الكندية لنا
حسن سواء تنمو الدباغة وحفر الزوج
unikato konu dvb-t jivu حادث مقاعد البدلاء
أكل تاتيانا آيس أستانا فاسيليف نعم
نعم المتحمسين
أوه إنها 100 ، اذهب بعيدًا عن التلكس مجانًا
قداس هاملت بدون دور هيفاء
امنحه بعيدا او اكسا الحقيقي 1
17 في مرأى من الجميع
أكل الحصاد الكامل
مع الكثير من الدببة ، ربما
لا تسير
إذا لم تظهر الهوامش هذا العام هنا ، إذن
سوف يهاجر الدببة العابرة
ادخل القرية
بالفعل كل هذا بهمينا ريما ووجدت ذلك وأنا
حصلت على doolin التزم الصمت بشأن هيدا
وأمي بقيت ألين باخاريف ليست روسيا
دباغة أنفسهم أسانا ومارثا معهم و
Russ a for no blowing 7 الفيزياء أ
البنفسجي
أعط آدم هنا ربطنا قبل شهر
40 ماسكارا متبقية من الهامش الذي
كانوا على ساحل القرية لماذا
جلبت هنا
من هنا يمكنك أن ترى بوضوح الدببة ، أي هم
يمكن السيطرة عليها
سبعة فظ صغير هنا اثنان
إله واحد كبير 2
مراهقة
أعتقد أن مات بالفعل بدأ الكلمة الأولى
الدب القطبي
[موسيقى]
فاديك مارشان لا يصلح
لم يسجل دبوس الشعر
[موسيقى]
على الشاطئ لديهم تكتيكات
دفع البحر يو إلى 7 يو
احضرنا المستنقع
استغرق
اذهب الكلاب
[موسيقى]
لقد سامحنا الجميع ، ونحن نرحل
الكمثرى بهدوء
بالنسبة لي هذا المكان أسعار المدينة للغاية
لأنهم
عاش هنا
أسلافهم على حق
نعم سوف نكرر
هذا هو المكان
كان ياران في منزلهم
أجداد الأجداد في كل منهما
هناك معسكر
رئيس هذا هو لي رتبة وكان الرئيسي
القيمة
[موسيقى]
تاتيانا - آلان تشوكشي أنا سفير
إيفان مينينكوف أوكرانيا ولكن على الرغم من الجدة
بيانات صد السيارات
ما زلت على آذان الكفرات ، أجعل حشدًا من الجلد
منازل مكعب كوموفا
في جميع أنحاء Chukotka إذا كنت تبدو جيدًا
كانت نقطتان عنيدتان للغاية
الذين أرادوا قبول السوفييت
قوة
بيلينغز وهنا سوقنا واكتب متى
اكتشف من اكتشف المحرض ما كان
جدي الأكبر إيفان إيفانوفيتش مينينكو
أرادوا إما إطلاق النار عليه أو نفيه
من هنا
[موسيقى]
كان على الاتفاق معهم.
تعاون وكان الرئيس
مزارع الفراء
لقد اعتبر بالفعل هذا المكان وطنه
ولد أطفاله هنا علم
هنا أصبح تشوكشي حقيقيًا ليعيشه
يقف ليهتف ليقرر
كله وهذا رجل نملة حقيقي
هناك شخص حقيقي
[موسيقى]
كم عدد الروس هناك
ثم تذهب للبحث عن عندما تحتاج
جمعت كل الزغابات وهنا
إنها ترضي على الأقل السترة التي أنت منها
هذا الصوف
يمكن أن يحدد الصوف نوع الدب
وهل يذهب باستمرار إلى نفس الشيء
المنطقة التي أريدها أن تكون
حساب موثوق ، على سبيل المثال ، حتى معنا
يقولون أنهم يكبرون بنسبة 20 من الدببة
يجمع في مكان واحد ، مما يعني
الكثير لدرجة أن الوقت قد حان بالنسبة لهم
الصيد ومحاولة شرح ما يجري
في الحقيقة هم ليسوا من حياة جيدة
تتجمع في مثل هذه الأكوام
لأن القليل من الجليد يكون كارثيًا
قليلا إلى 100
ونرى هنا ويضاف الماء
وهذا يعني أن الساحل يغادرنا ببطء
تحت الماء
[موسيقى]
هذه مجموعة كبيرة هذه جزيرة من حيوانات الفظ
يأملون بعضهم البعض
لا تخشى الخروج على الماء
لم يخرج
انظر بعد كل ما فعلته ميناموتو
متراصة asw-r
وعمدا أو غيره من المتسللين عثمان
1tatyana feat loc مرة أخرى 0 ناقص إعطاء
أعطيت جانبًا من مكالماتي الهاتفية
صاخبة مزدوجة
[موسيقى]
تجعلني أشعر بالصراخ
تعمل مثل هذا إذا كنت أحمق مثل هذا
تفعل ذلك وتحزم رفع إذا
هناك شيء ما بالقرب منه
طرق على هذا السطح سيكون صاخبة
خلق التأثير بصوت أعلى كلما كان ذلك أفضل
أشفق على حلقك
[تصفيق]
هنا هذا التهديد لكنه في البريد و
تحمل إعلانات معلقة في كل مكان مع
أرقام هواتفنا هي بالضبط ما
نحن نفعل هذا من أجل
حماية الناس يتحمل الرجل بالترتيب
لا تقتلهم
هكذا لدينا سيف ذو حدين
نحن بين المطرقة والسندان
يقول شكرا لك منذ الصغر حلمت
أصبح عضوا في دورية الدب
نعم لا كانت طفولتي مختلفة بشكل جيد
كان في مكان ما في أعماقي
في الداخل ، طُلب مني أولاً المساعدة هناك
على الفظ على الحقائب ، أدركت أن هذا ملكي
وكل شيء وأنا أطلبه بشكل خاص
عام 2006 ، عندما ظهرت حيوانات الفظ وباين
هناك أكثر من 50 منهم
عدد السكان المجتمع المحلي
لقد ألهموا الحق على المغدفة بالفؤوس و
وقتل الأنياب
ينظر إلى هذا الشيء
أنا هنا على الخط الأمامي وبعد ذلك
ينظم المتطوعون كل ساعة
تم تنظيم الساعة
عام 2007 طُلب مني من قبل VVF بأكمله
راقبت الدببة والصنادل
مرحبًا بشخص آخر يحكم بدقة
احصل على توصيل أو تموت بابا كوماري سالاتو
كسر تاتيانا الجافة airan utakata
علم صالة السينما والسينما كاميرا وماذا فعلت
تناثر الريش في جميع أنحاء المدخل ، لم يفعل
سأقوم بالتنظيف بعدك من الملاك
نظف
كيف لا أنظف لن أنظف نفسي
أنا أنظف شخصًا ما سيخبرك بالمال مقابل ذلك
يدفع لكنه بالتأكيد لا يدفع ثمن هذا و
لدي خمسة منازل أخرى مثل هذا لاحقًا
لا يزال لدي وظيفة بدوام جزئي كبواب عندما
آخذ المدخل عندما نقوم بتنظيف الساحات
نحن نتحدث عن التنظيف الشامل على الأقل
على البصق
على الشاطئ ، ولكن أي نوع من الناس هناك
تريد إزالته
[موسيقى]
لذلك اتضح أن لا أحد يحتاج إلى أي شيء سوى
بعد كل شيء ، سيكون لطيفًا على الشاطئ النظيف
يجب أن يكون المشي مالكًا حقيقيًا
رجل لديه المزيد من الروح
لكل شيء من حوله
يد على القانون الجديد
لمن بعض الفانيليا
[موسيقى]
تجاوز اللعنة
يقود الرجل
لقد رأيت 4 حفيدات فقط بالداخل
أول
نعم تاتيانا فيدورينا هذا العام هالك أيديم
عناوين الهاتف التي هي حقا طهارة
يهز الكراسي
أو الياس التدقيق استبعاد التندرا أو
amalko ليس بعد ظهر اليوم سيتو من هاف لاجونز
هذا أسادا لهذه المازة بمهارة لدي
توصل إليها بابا أوليا أنه أونا سولا و
جعل قاصر
[موسيقى]
سيكون من الجيد أنك ما زلت تعمل في ahab 1
مارثا
هذا هو القارب من السفينة الآن
ينتهك
أنظمة
حفر أيضا في
دخله
وبالتالي فإن المشي ممنوع هنا
القوارب
في حدود 2 3 5
أخاف lapta كل الدببة
كانوا هناك
قفزت الدببة في الجانب الشرقي كل شيء
في الماء
ذهب ذهب ذهب ذهب متسارع
من فضلك لا تخاف
deuc soo hyuna bang body care army
لأن تاتيانا أو وكل شيء على ما يرام
عناء مقسم أكثر
[موسيقى]
هذه المهمة هي الأراضي الحدودية التي
تعتبر طرق هجرة الحيوانات
هذه الغداء لهم أن يغادروا الرصاص
العمل التوضيحي و
يعاقب
أخبرني أنني مررت
حرس الحدود
نعم
إلى حد كبير كان لديه سباحة كبيرة
الدببة مع اثنين من الأشبال
لا عفا عليها الزمن ولم تذهب حيث تكمن
اثنان يحمل اثنين من الذكور لأن الذكور
يمكن أن تقتل الأشبال خاصة
علف مفقود لي وأكله
يمكن للناس أن يشربوا الآن
بشكل عام ، أخاف هذا القارب الجميع
[موسيقى]
وتاتيانا لديه صك وقائد هو نفسه
نفس الشيء بالنسبة للخطوات إلى 2 مقدار واحد من النجاح
تاريخ overcard الألم
بيو لي. وفي نفس الوقت أنا
[موسيقى]
لاحظ أن لديهم علاقة قوية
أسلافنا أمهاتنا آباؤنا الذين ليس لديهم
بالفعل أنفسهم
انها ليست دائما في الجوار
خاصة عند العودة إلى هؤلاء
أماكن من حيث الخاص بك
[موسيقى]
يمكن اعتبار ذلك
نظرًا لأننا حصلنا عليها ، فنحن بحاجة إلى استخدامها
ها هو البرنامج الكامل وشخص بهذا
الفلسفة تعيش في الواقع هنا الناس
الذين قطعوا هذه الغابة وهكذا
تعيش بائسة على وجه التحديد من هذه الدبابير و
هذا هو المكان الذي ستكون فيه الصحراء الثلاثمائة القادمة
سنوات القفر تماما
التي سيتم تجاوزها
لن تكون الخنازير والأوعية الأرضية فقط
يبدو أن النوع من لا يجب أن يكون
لم يكن طريقي إلى حماية الطبيعة سهلاً
اخترت المسار أولا و
مهندس تعدين
عملت على حفارة كبيرة للمشي
والتي في ثانية واحدة يمكن أن تهدم 15
مكعبات التربة وبطريقة ما
فيديو زارا وراء رافعات هذا الضخم
حفارة رأيت جبلًا آخر يسقط
أعطى الأزرق أدركت فجأة
هنا
هذه الأسهم أكثر أهمية بالنسبة لي
ما أفعله وأصبح علماء أحياء
الصيادين أنا لست نادما على ذلك على الإطلاق
انا افعل ما احب
محادثة طبيعية
[موسيقى]
منظمة وخلفية سلمية حصة مثل
كندا والعمل 25 عاما
الضفدع من جلد الغزال بوما
[موسيقى]
ولكن بصراحة فعلت كاتيا معها
عدد كاف من الزملاء
ولكن لا يزال هناك القليل
تأكد من أننا نضمن
بقاء هذا المفترس
تحرك الطبيعة لأن النمر ليس كذلك
مجرد الخوف المفترس كرة السلة meizu
القطط
مؤشر هنا
الحالة الصحيحة للطبيعة
التي نعيشها مادام كل شيء خير منك
[موسيقى]
فيتامين
shiroyama يو فيج لا وله
ماركاسيت ا و ليفي اليكسييف كندا و غاز
رمي ذكرى الخليفة بول وهذا العام
هناك عرب
مجموعة كاملة من الكلاسيكيات تقريبًا
من القائد أنه فيدي استخرجته من الهدية
قتلت إيرينا تعتقد أن أعداد من اتحاد القوزاق
لا تشارك في المهرجان وكانوا أصدقاء مع إلياس
كيلومتر ومن ثم موهوب جدا من شاشات الكريستال السائل
القطن على النظام الغذائي للأمهات وإلى أي مدى أنت
غرفة مستشفى القوزاق لتلك العزامات
أخذت aiko مما جعلني بالفعل
محدب لا للهواء ما زلت هادئا و
ثريا ama paul guna ملف نذل رقيقة
وليام في الصيف من نفس الصاروخ من أجل ما يصل إلى الحافة
حظًا سعيدًا أو ازدهر مبكرًا
مركز التأهيل الكسيف اليوم
في الصباح نضع حبيبي واليونان
القوزاق
يجب إذا شلت من أجل
اليوم ، بالطائرة ، انقله إلى
بعيد كراسنويارسك وجاهز للإعجاب
أكل نفسك
[موسيقى]
وميل آخر للقوزاق
وأعطي اسم أو رئيس دير داريوس
حظائر الطائرات أو المباعة في الماضي
في المواقع شموا 2 أوم من القوزاق
عشاق
بطرسبرغ أضيف أقل ديفيد بيل
أذهب مي ألما شاهين أورال
بالطبع بابو dalek 1 مشهد الهروب نعم و
أوليغ ألفيرو من
يعطي الرأس كرر بينما أنا
صفراء
[موسيقى]
كذلك لأنه
هذه تسع عمليات ، لكن هذا
صعب نفسيًا وأنا دائمًا
حاولت إعادة تأهيل نعم هذا كل ما عندي
لا يزال أكثر أو أقل من النخيل بشكل كامل
التنمية هي أهم عمل يمكن أن يصل إليه
افعل ما لا نهاية بنفسك
شهادة دبلوم
نمر الشبل
واتضح حجم الكلب
الناس بالطريقة التي تتبعنا بها هذا
نمر الشبل
الأم ، تم العثور عليها ، كنا خائفين من ذلك بدون
أمهات
سأفعل 40 دقيقة على شاشة الكاميرا
ازدهرت اقترب الفلاحون
النمور بشكل عام أكثر إثارة للاهتمام على شاشة التلفزيون
قل لي ، هل كان هناك أي
قصص هنا ألعاب العام الماضي
يُسأل بقرة مثل هذه الأيام للناس أن هناك
برنامج للتعويض عن هذا الضرر
ولكن من أجل ذلك يجب أن تكونا معًا
يجب مراعاتها
قياس الأثر على سبيل المثال انظر هنا
إذا كنا على القمامة البيضاء Janek و
الفيزياء وعلى هذا [ __ ] له ارتدائه
اسم windu لهم isotherm كان له رداء
hayatim بالعقل هولينا تير كادوني
الكاتيل تايوان
شكرا لكم جميعا حظا سعيدا هنا
[موسيقى]
حفر العين
[تصفيق]
كانوا خارج الخدمة لمدة عام تقريبًا
في الآونة الأخيرة شعرت
أفضل قليلاً من قبل ولكن بصراحة
شعرت بالسوء
[موسيقى]
ملعقة
على ال
العطر
هذه الحاوية ممتلئة
قتل جثث الحيوانات البرية
هذه الجثث الفعلية
سيذهب إلى مركز التشخيص هذا
أمراض الحيوان
من أجل مدينة أوسوريسك المجيدة
كان هناك خاص
فحوصات الطب الشرعي البيولوجية
وفقًا للابن للمشي gigolos و اللعنة عليه
سنواتك un amor amor
Fionova ، أي أنه من الضروري خان بمبلغ 180 av
اج الجحيم وبيوت الرب على البحر الناري
ومن أجل هانسن ركلتك على هؤلاء الناس
شيري انا لست سيئا. سوق ضخمة
له الشعير أوليا ميلا من الصوت له
التأقلم
otita te ik fairy riddle on wate tori
أبيض على
في كثير من الأحيان نتلقى المنتجات
يمكن بيعها بما يكفي
المال الوفير خاصة في البلدان
منطقة آسيا والمحيط الهادئ هي منطقتنا
المهمة هي فهم كيف عمدا
هل كان هذا الحيوان الذي نحتاجه لفهم هذا
فعلت كما فعلت هي في الواقع
يخبرنا حيوان ميت
أكثر بكثير من السكنية
فتاة جميلة وأبي جدا
الشرطة الأحاسيس الشباب بطريقة أو بأخرى
كان لديه ذرية في الآونة الأخيرة
بيريتا
من الواضح كم ، لكن أشبال النمر بالتأكيد
كانت ولكن ربما تعرضت للهجوم
أكثر
نعم كان هناك المزيد
لدينا منزل بمال حقيقي
سوف نفهم
يرتفع على الرغم من عمله أو العثور عليه
استجابة
الشخص المناسب سوف يعود
أرى وجوه غابات باشاناليا من أجل ماذا
حدث هنا
لذلك نحن الآن في السهول الفيضية للنهر
بلو هيل أول جروب
الغابات والغابات خاصة حماية المياه
تم تعيين الغابات هنا على الأرجح
قطع انتقائي طوعي ولكن
الشجرة العشرون رماد وعزيز
أعيد بناء الخشب لعمر
تتناسب مع عدم وجود
القيمة الاقتصادية فقط
يجب أن يكون الحطب أولاً
يتم تعيين قائمة الانتظار للمجموعة التي تتوقف
سأترك موقع youtube أيضًا
لكن هناك شيء آخر يعني أن الشجرة رماد وجاف
قمة أنواع الخشب أيضا
مهجورة وهناك نرى ذلك تمامًا
الشباب الأصحاء
على الرغم من أنني سأخلع مسدسات الاحتكاك قليلاً
فوق الرأس
وهذه هي المشكلة حينها ستصبح
السحرية و Grodno مصنوعة بشكل أساسي
أكثر الجيوب ضعفا من هذا الوضع
الحيوانات التي تعيش في هذا نحن
تحتها من الضروري ضبط الغابة
التشريع في هذا
مجموعة مصفوفة
الأزرق اثنين
وفقا لنا.
قبل سبع سنوات كان هناك 0
زيادة ذوات الحوافر بشكل ملحوظ
وعمليا انخفض إلى 0 0 مكان زواج
حسنًا ، وفقًا لذلك ظهر لك
طلب الغرير 8 مارس
اخبار خلع هذا الجمال والذكور
هناك عندما ترى بأم عينيك حيوانًا أنت
يمكنك تقييم معالمها
نوع من الجرح كل منهما
النمر له رسمه الخاص ، وهذا هو ، في الواقع
الأشياء مثل بصمات الأصابع وهذا
يسمح لنا أن نفهم حتى عندما
نفس حجم البصمة لدينا
النمور تعيش هنا
هذا دب غادر بالفعل
مخابئ لا تخرج من الجوع الآن هو
بدس ، بما في ذلك هنا على هذه
لن أحمل مغذيات فمن الضروري هنا في هذا
الجو
هذه هي الأشياء الصغيرة التي يجب أن يكون لديهم بالفعل
تقريبًا هذا يعني أنه هنا وهناك
قل أن الصيادين تم إدخال غرفة بخار خفيفة
نوع من الحدائق وحش
إنه وحش إنه بني ضخم
أعتقد أنه دب من عندنا
إنه قريب جدًا ، إنه جيد
مكان ما في الوحوش البرية
يتحرك جيئة وذهابا
[موسيقى]
ماذا او ما
دعنا نذهب ، حسنًا ، سنصاب بالتأكيد بالعدوى
بدا الأطباء تحسنوا بشكل مدهش
قائلا اذهب الى العمل اخرج
وزن جلب هنا لا أحد لا شيء
لا يأتي حتى يتم أخذ تخدير النهر
ضعه على الغاز ثم أعط الأمر
ترسل عندما يمكنك البقاء على قيد الحياة وشيء هنا
هذا مهم
حسب تقديراتنا ، فالكحول غير كاف
تحت السيارة
من الواضح أنه حصل بعد ذلك على آخر
كشط مهم من الحياة
[موسيقى]
تعرض للهجوم من قبل رفاقه من رجال القبائل دون محاكمة
على الخطى التي لسنا جميعًا على استعداد لها
أكلت أكثر من ذلك بقليل
[موسيقى]
عقد الطلاق بالكرة ونفس الشيء سيكون أسوأ
بخفة صلاته صور غوغل له
عائلة الحساب هي kalifa بينما أنا مقرف
ومنح ذلك المعزَّمة تلك الحفرة
الأسماك في المستقبل المسار جيد جدًا
عملت توربو الصيد الإشراف بريمورسكي
حواف وذهب على الفور إلى المكان
زيارة مرجل الحيوان
عمل مركز أليكسيف بشكل جيد للغاية
الدخان الآن خارج
بالطبع ، بفضل المحترمين
طبيب
من عيادة نيك البيطرية نحن هنا
نحن قادرون على العمل
شفاء هذا الحيوان أو الطازج في 10
أيام تعليقات التقدم الملموس
كم حصلنا على كتاب مثل هذا
يمكنك أن ترى أنه كان ضروريًا ، حسنًا ، هذا هو سحب المياه
من أسلحتهم من الحظ هذا درس
تبين أنها مقاتلة مقهى ساخنة واضحة
أنه بدون مساعدة الناس هذا الحيوان
لقد مات بالفعل
[موسيقى]
أنطاليا
وما يصل إلى اثنين من الجان لامبورغيني
فطائر فوا والعقل واحد ميثيل الليل
[موسيقى]
هو على تكتيك
فجأة ننجح يا شباب
تطبيق تدابير الصودا سيكون
فوز
سيكون هناك طقس
[موسيقى]
العميل الجاهز
نرى من هي العملية أكثر أو أقل
تحركت سأبدأ التجديد له
من الضروري أن تعيش في كثير من الأحيان الأشغال الشاقة
لهم بإذن الله الرجل الصقر
شيموس 10
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شاشة الغاز على عشاء u1 الوفير لادا
فيستا نعم حيث كانت لعبة ساجديفا تدور حول هاواي
مخلوق من نوع مختلف يعيش للوحات
yakumo له ture igor karyakin للفة
داشا سليات
السيد لقد أعطيت ثقوب حرب لدى العرب
الأسطورة هي فقط لديك الوقت برج آل
نرى هيئة التصنيع العسكري لأن هذه
يتم ترتيب حضانة الطيور
السكان الطبيعيين هم أي كبار السن
طوابق المنتدى
لكن مع ذلك هذه الأسطورة باللغة العربية
البلدان مدعومة و
[موسيقى]
أنا مستعد لدفع المزيد مقابل طائر بري
من نيكولاس يوجه لصالح الأعمى يا
أفضل
[موسيقى]
وأنا متزوج من علي كوناه أوركيد مع أي شخص
فريدة مع الصدر 0 ميل من الاستياء
تحرك المصارعة أو rf واحد رائع
العقل الأفقي والتين سارة سورغانوفا
ويلفر أشولد الجوز كل رجل زوجة بي بي سي
الكتان قبالة ودوريات ألو أوليا الطبيعة هي
أو هذا مرحبا انها الحمامات
[موسيقى]
سينما تعويض ترميم جدا
السينما والأدب karjakin nikolenko io
مشاهدة البيانات فيلم التراجع و
علة أو إعطاء شرائط بطارية ignatiev
Elite Beck Aveo Bel سوف يعطي من David
nikolenko توها دولفر الاسم المستعار عنبية نفس
روبي سيبيريا
لقد تجاوزت هذا بالفعل في Igor Karyakin
خضروات وفطائر anel 0 من 5 طن
[موسيقى]
يطلب
لقد تجولنا الآن في المنطقة بدا
لمدة 4 اتضح أننا سنحرر الأعشاش هناك
معجزة ما زلنا جالسين
عش واحد هناك سترات صغيرة أسفل و
الكثير من الكلاب الجائعة لكل دورجا
من هذه 5 فراخ والآباء بالكاد
التعامل معهم ش إطعامهم
على المرء
نزلنا الآن العش الذي عليه
الاستنتاجات
سيتم تدمير لوبانوف بواسطة حيوان مفترس كبير
ربما بومة النسر تكمن بقايا الجثث
تحت العش
وفقًا لذلك ، تم زرع هذا العش
لن يكون لدينا فراخ لأنها كذلك
سوف يأكل البوزادنيك في الشتاء
لذلك نحن نبحث الآن عن
أعشاش بديلة وسنذهب إلى هناك
جالس
كابتن بنطلون أو كولين باول المطا
هل هم على قناتها Mihal yanai detya
كنت أبحث عن جامع الحراك لهم بالفعل
يمكنني أن أذهب بشكل أسرع أيضًا
نظرة
قليلا الى الوراء
[موسيقى]
و أنا
[تصفيق]
رقم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا رئيس الجامعة
لفهم مدى فعالية
القضايا التي نحتاج إلى معرفة مصير كل منها
الطيور في روسيا حتى في صوت باكستان
البحث عن مارجا تعقب الإشارات
متوترين هنا قمنا بقياس الكتاكيت
تم وضع علامة على جهاز الإرسال هنا هو المرسل
على ظهره
فقط هو حريص
نقطة ترسل العش مرة أخرى إذا كنا
نتحدث عن الصيد الجائر
الصقر هو بالطبع
الماسك المحترفين لكن هذا
المهاجرين من سوريا أقل تواترا والجبن والسوراكوي
إذا كانت الآراء من البلدان الأخرى كلها
اشتعلت الحياة بفصل الألوان
بينما يوجد 25000 صقر تعشيش
من منطقة موسكو إلى معدن التاي إليها
الأخضر عند كل هؤلاء السكان
عازمة جميع الصيادين اندفع جثم رمح ل
ورقة في Khakassia حددت مجموعة من 12
الرجل وتسوية تنجذب إلينا
وزن المقيم المحلي كيفية إزالة ذلك
المبلغ الذي سيحصل عليه السوريون من الصقور
هو أنه يدفع للسكان المحليين على الإطلاق
تافه البنسات
الماشية تجلب المزيد حقًا
أمر من هذا كيس الحب غير القانوني
ولكن للأسف الحمار عقلية والناس
من العقل الملموس يعتمد على أنا vai vai
أمي لا تنتظر
[موسيقى]
يتضح أن السيد الأكثر حدودًا للمخلوقات
con el hana and leonid وقد تفحص بالفعل
قام Meisu بتدخين Gasol Miller وهو متمسك بـ
تمتص ألبر لدي والدي وأمي يأكلان و
أعشاش تنبح filchikov
يقيسون المنقار ويخرجه والدي
ريشة واحدة مع أنبوبه و
يضعك نائمًا فماذا تفعل بعد ذلك التحليل
عزيزي الرجاء إحضار الذرات
مقطع إلى شرائح
[موسيقى]
اوه شكرا لك
انتظر انتظر سحب ليس كل شيء مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
حقيبة في الهند طوال الوقت
جالسًا أمام الكمبيوتر طوال اليوم
التقرير لا يقول شيئا على الإطلاق
من الضروري التنبؤ بكل هذه الطيور
اذهب واشعر بمكان واحد
يجب أن لفة
إذا كان الوقت لنا عندما كنت هنا
الماء الأول وكأنني لم يبق أنا لست كذلك
أكلت أثناء القيادة ، كان كل شيء على هذا النحو
الطاقة كتبت فوق هذه الجبال
الحجارة لأنها طاقة سوداء
في السنوات الأخيرة ، لم نلتقي بسبب
تجمع على متن الطائرة
تخيل كيف
في أنا
لديّ أيضًا قاعدة حديدية في الليل
محرك وقوف السيارات منخفضة تنجح بشكل خاص
تضاريس
[موسيقى]
نيكول عن عمليات بث الصور وشرائحها
hh.ua المكعب الأفقي هي من نوع ما
إلا بالله
[موسيقى]
نحن مستهلكون هذه الإمارات العربية
قوانين قطر والمملكة العربية السعودية
يكفي ، هذا هو ، مجموعة مع
التجارة محظورة لكنها مستمرة
ضغط دوليًا
قرار منغوليا حتى الآن
تباع البلوغا بشكل قانوني
صقور الحر المنغولية لا يهتمون بها
نحن عالقون في الهجرات ونحن جميعا
الهجرة من خلال المانجا
[موسيقى]
تم أخذ الكتاكيت بعيدًا ليتم حلقها
عينات
بدلا من القياس ثم جنبا إلى جنب مع دور الحضانة
مهارة العجل والنبات بالفعل
يمكن توسيع العش المحسن
حتى لا يصلوا إلى الشتاء
[موسيقى]
السمنة على الجميع ستغطي الموقع
بالتأكيد الصقارين العرب لديهم
موسم التقاليد من اصطياد الطيور
أطلق سراح ولكن المشكلة هي أن فقط وليس
فقط مثل هذا أخذ الطائر في
نفسنا تنهار هناك وتستمر
الجوع طوال الوقت لأنه
المقدسة والطائر لن يكون جيدا رغم ذلك
ظروف الحرارة
تم إطلاق سراحهم للتو وجميع هذه الطيور
نسبة تسعين بالمائة جديدة يموتون
حتى البحر لا يمكن أن يطير لأنه
أنت فقط لا تعرف جزيرتي
من lvovich
ألينا في يو آه دو أو إثيرات
المؤتة أو
أو مرآب أولئك الذين يطيرون بالضبط إلى المدخل
حتى العارية الخاصة بك
ألفيرا كوزاك
la-la-la أجرة لهم من oauth2 ما هو
من المهم أن تأخذ الأشكال
أو الأخت واضحة على المرأة بعد
يستحق التوبيخ
يبتعد
[موسيقى]
لقب القهوة في هذا العش
أعلى خلع الملابس
هذا هو الاستنتاج الأخير والذي نحن
تتجدد مع الكتاكيت في هذا الموقع و
الآن دعنا نذهب إلى الجبال
حيث لن نضع تدريبات بعد الآن
غير شجرية التعشيش صقر الصقر والعلوم
أنا الأميرة سارة تسكور من الهجمات و
القراد 20 قطعة
ألقى بنعم وذهل يبحث عن شهر أو لذلك أنا
لقد شربت بالفعل نصف الباقي
انتظر انتظر ماذا لا اصور الان
[موسيقى]
عدد غير قليل لذلك هم فقط أفكر في كل شيء
اثني عشر رفع يديك سوف تتركهم فقط
[موسيقى]
لدي تسعة وثمانين أكتاف
التهاب الدماغ والخياطة و 1 التهاب الدماغ
لكنها كانت صعبة بما فيه الكفاية
اشتعلتني الصداع الناتج عن ارتفاع درجات الحرارة
20 عاما من الرحلة الاستكشافية
بشكل عام ، أصابني التهاب الدماغ مرة أخرى
وتملك بعد ذلك 2 التهاب الدماغ
لدي
[موسيقى]
هنا بدأت الحساسية الحادة
يمكن القول أن المتلازمة مكتسبة
يمكن أن يقال هناك العديد من الوظائف
التهاب الدماغ و الداء النزفي و النزفي
الحمى في الثالثة المهنية
الأمراض
اذا الناس
يقضي الكثير من الوقت في الغابة و
يصلح الحيوانات في مجموعة الإسعافات الأولية الخاصة بنا
تناول الطعام بشكل صحيح دائمًا في المناسبات الأولى
الطاعون وتولاريميا الكوليرا
تصاعدت النزفية ثم أصبحت ممتلئة
المجموعة ليست محظوظة جدًا للجميع
ونقلت أين هو هذه الأمراض الرهيبة
القبض
مشى لا يوجد جواب واحد نعم أنا سيمون
أطلقت على نفسي 10 قطع وهو يقترب من 100
لقد وصلنا الآن إلى
منتجة من حيث الأجور ولكن بين أو
ملقة هنا دائمًا زوجان من الصقور لديها 5
الوحدات ، ولكن لأن هذه المنطقة في كل مكان
والمحطة نفسها معيبة من حيث الإمدادات الغذائية
بقائهم هنا ضعيف معنا
عش تحت هذه الحافة ونحن حتى لا
يمكننا أن نرى ما بداخلها
الكتاكيت التي أريد بيضة بعد ثلاث
كتكوت بيضة واحدة
على الأرجح غير مخصب
لقد أنقذت الكتكوت ، هل يمكنك إخباره
أخوين أكبر منه يتم طردهما من العش و
زحف إلى الخارج ولم يطعمه والديه
العام الماضي بفضل هبوط ثلاثة
وصولا إلى منزل الكتاكيت الأربعة الأصلية
المغادرة
من سيتحكم سواك
هذا الوقت في مكانه إذن
أو لست مضطرًا لمضغ وضع إيليا
قولها الحالي
الفوضى وكيف أنا
[موسيقى]
في الجزء العلوي من المكياج حركات طبقة dun للرمادي
الأسماك على المنصة
[موسيقى]
ولكن ماذا تطعم رؤوس مجموعة من الخيار
يعيش الإرهاق النشط لا رمى لا
سقطت منذ فترة طويلة لذلك اعتقدت ذلك
الآن نحن صغيرون بإخلاص
قطع من المال
وسيبدأ في التعافي
الأنسجة العضلية طبقة الدهون
يكبر وسوف نطلق سراحه مرة أخرى
بشكل طبيعي بين المهزلة
ما بين
[موسيقى]
لذلك أقاموا مصيدة للصور
جلست الكتاكيت اللقيط الأصلي أثناء ذلك
ما يقرب من يوم في المدينة وبعد ذلك هذا
أصبحوا أصدقاء والجميع والآن معًا الآن
انتظر ولكن في الواقع مهمتنا
فراخ المعتوه منتهية الجلوس عبر
ولكن أعشاش الطيور البرية
العائلات
العملية تسير جنرالنا
وأظهرت المراقبة بالفيديو أن الجنرال
كتاكيت جيدة يتبناها الوالدان تغذيهما
لقد مرت بالفعل إعصارين في واحد
كرسي 3 فراخ عادوا
هناك فرصة أن نفعل ذلك في يوم من الأيام
دعونا ننتظر حتى يتم إطلاق سراح عازفي الطبول لدينا
مرة أخرى هنا سوف يتكاثرون
كل صياد رحيلهم
كل شخص لديه روح غريبة و
على الجسم
لكننا نفعل الكثير للطبيعة
جروح رهيبة عميقة
هل ستغفر لنا الطبيعة ، لهذا لا أفعل
أنا أعرف
[موسيقى]
قد لا يغفر
القانون قانون ومبدأ جيد
ينبغي للقانون بشكل طبيعي
ضمان الحفاظ على الأنواع النادرة
لينا لا تعمل لأن السياح
رقم
[موسيقى]
سخيف نقي وبريء
مثل فتاة خجولة
الحبوب الزرقاء
في بعض الأحيان الريكي
صباحا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حول
[موسيقى]